le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
installation des jeunes agriculteurs
mécanisation irrigation création d'un
mât pays dans le domaine agricole
le département dispose d'un éventail
dead spécifique mais jusqu'ici aucune ne
ciblait les agriculteurs indépendants
qui représentent pourtant 80% de la
production locale de fruits et légumes
cette année la collectivité expérimente
donc une subvention dédié à ces
cultivateurs une aide sur les produits
de la vie courante
fortement concurrencé par l'importation
[Musique]
c'est le rendez vous hebdomadaire du
quartier des camélias tous les vendredis
c'est ici que les visiteurs viennent
chercher leurs fruits et légumes frais
frais mais pas toujours pays sur les
étals des carottes des oignons ou de
l'ail d'origine étrangère une différence
de prix est de taille ici à gauche
les carottes pays peine à s'imposer face
au gigantisme à la chinoise de quoi
dégoûter ceux qui jouent dans les règles
chez nous mais en fait c'est pour
rétablir la balance que le département
vient de mettre en place une nouvelle
mesure en faveur des cultivateurs locaux
dans les eaux de petites îles et divi de
sa terre depuis presque trente ans comme
la majorité des agriculteurs de l'île
il exerce en indépendant ce matin il
doit éclaircir une partie de son champ
de carottes tous les mois je sommes une
force est c'est durant là comme
d'habitude c'est manuellement et après
comme vous voyez là c'est faire la
machine
la mécanisation ces sons se voir
mécanique et deal à acheter avec ses
propres moyens
contrairement aux coopératives les
agriculteurs indépendants ne percevait
jusqu'à maintenant aucune aide ni parce
que les suffisamment dit le département
leur propose désormais une subvention
sur des productions cible est menacé par
l'importation
je pense notamment à la carotte au
gingembre au safran également à l'ail
l'oignon ce sont des cultures phare de
la réunion où la ménagère utilise
quasiment tous les jours dans sa cuisine
et aujourd'hui nous subissons de plein
fouet
l'importation de ces produits sur une
liste de onze produits
l'agriculteur devra choisir celui pour
lequel il veut être subventionné sans
possibilité de cumuler l'aide est de
l'ordre de 4000 euros sauf pour l'ail et
l'oignon ou cette aide est porté à 8000
euros
ce soutien est un soutien fort un
soutien significatif
c'est véritablement pour relancer
l'ensemble des produits identitaires que
nous connaissons à la réunion
des produits comme l'ail dont la culture
est déjà complexe
là il fait feu dormant sinon vous pouvez
la plante et s'il n'ya pas le délai de
respecter à varages m c'est pour ça
qu'il est aussi chez à la revente
parce que déjà c'est c'est la semence et
elle est chère
le coût de plantation et non un travail
de patience qui porte ses fruits ou en
l'occurrence ces gosses c'est la botte
que je vais participer au concours de la
plus belle bataille dont j'ai obtenu le
premier prix cette année
personnellement le goût cela il est
beaucoup plus accentuée plus faut que
j'aille d'après la qualité et la
tradition
deux valeurs que cultive fièrement
l'agriculteur l'ail et l'oignon c'était
le parent le grand parents car quand les
admissions en place cette tradition
c'est une bonne initiative de la
collectivité je pense ans pour inciter
les agriculteurs à produire certaines
certaines cultures
ça va dans le bon sens et on va pouvoir
peut-être à cuire et des dés de la
mécanisation avec cette aide
et comme je dis peut-être au final le
consommateur il va payer moins cher
chaque année 35 mille tonnes de fruits
et légumes sont importés à la réunion
contre 100 mille tonnes de productions
locales
parmi ces produits l'aï pays ne couvre
que 4 % des besoins les oignons pays 10%
et le volume de carottes importé est
deux fois plus important que la
production locale l'aide départementale
pour les producteurs indépendants
proposent une subvention allant de 4000
à 8000 euros selon le produit et le
tonnage la subvention s'appliquent à
onze produits dont 7 de consommation
courante pour plus d'informations ou
pour accéder au formulaire de demande
vous pouvez consulter le site du
département au www.cglpl.fr ou appeler
le numéro vert 0 800 000 490
[Musique]